l'évaluation des risques professionnels
des postes occupés par les femmes sont
probablement connus de tous au même
titre que ceux des hommes ils sont
évalués de la même façon en fait il n'y
a pas de spécificité de genre certaines
expositions sont même
connu pour être spécifiquement à risque
pour les femmes donc c'est le cas du
travail de nuit vous live souligné ou le
risque de cancer du sein chez la femme
est un risque identifié pour lequel la
surveillance du risque a fait l'objet
d'une recommandation de bonnes pratiques
qui a été labellisée en 2012 par la
chasse et c'est à peu près le seul chose
que
qui est un peu spécifique
il semble en revanche que les risques
professionnels dans les secteurs
professionnels plutôt féminin ne soit
pas suffisamment maîtrisé au regard de
certains secteurs plutôt masculins vous
avez cité de nettoyage c'est plutôt un
secteur très féminin
de même les spécificités liées au fait
que le poste soit occupé par une femme
sont pas suffisamment perçus sauf dans
le cas précis de l'état de grossesse ou
de l'allaitement ou le lien entre santé
exposition professionnelle chez la femme
alerte presque systématiquement les
employeurs et donc les visites chez les
médecins du travail sont souvent
déclenchés donc soit par l'employeur
soit par la salarié elle-même qui dans
cet état là on va dire va se signaler
et non dans ces cas là des aménagements
de poste sont en généralement
préconisés et sont généralement non plus
pas contester ce qui est ce qui est un
peu important
par contre il y a pas suffisamment c'est
vrai une prise de conscience de
spécificité telle que les spécificités
anthropométriques ou physiologiques des
femmes dans la conception par exemple
des postes de travail
aujourd'hui il poste du travail peuvent
être occupés aussi bien par des hommes
et par des femmes
et cependant voilà les les conditions
dans lequel on crée aujourd'hui les
postes sont souvent normés du coup sur
des sur des des mesures masculines et
donc ça ça peut générer par contre des
maladies professionnelles par exemple en
milieu de production la conception de
lignes de montage ou de production
prennent pour référence entre pays
métriques des mesures masculines ainsi
les postes de travail sont souvent en
plus non réglables donc elles sont peu
adaptées au gabarit des femmes et ça
c'est un risque d'apparition de TMS par
exemple
[Musique]